hey everybody what's going on happy
Sunday hope your weekend's been going
good how's everybody doing out there
what are you laughing before just funny
um okay so uh today's Godfather Three
yeah we finally got around to watching
this
we know it as Godfather Three but it um
Francis Ford Coppola at the beginning of
this you could see a little intro before
before before the movie starts and we
selected to see it
this is actually the original title
which is called uh [ __ ] uh The
Godfather coda coda the death of Michael
Corley is what it's called this was the
2020 re-edit yeah and he said that they
they changed some stuff so this is not
the this is not the original edit
they changed the order of certain scenes
and I think they changed the ending a
bit
yeah I was like I was trying to look at
what the differences were um there's a
different opening scene and the end of
the movie
um is slightly different I mean nothing
different happens it's just that they
cut it before yeah he before he actually
like slumps over and dies and I think
they just rearranged some but from what
I could determine it's not that
different from the theatrical cut this
is evidently what Coppola wanted yeah so
you know it's just so it's kind of
restored yeah which that's good
um it's a good movie
it's not a great movie not as good as
the other two but it's a good movie I
think the main thing that held this one
back was that it's taken place many
years later when when Michael Corleone
is older and most of the guys he's
dealing with are older guys and they're
in a much more elevated
they're in a much more elevated setting
you know their uh leaders of big
corporations and dealing with the damn
Pope and the Vatican and everything
so it's not quite as gritty
um
it's a little slower
but it's not a bad movie
it's good
it's just I think the thing about this
one is that the first two were so good
yeah that I mean anything was gonna be
especially you know because they waited
such a long time to make this that you
know any movie is gonna suffer a little
bit by comparison and I think that's
kind of the overarching opinion about
this I think when it first came out like
it got kind of mixed reviews it did
still get nominated for best picture and
a bunch of awards and stuff like I don't
think it won any Oscars but it got
nominated for a bunch but I kind of feel
like a lot of critics at the time were
like basically saying pretty much the
same thing it's like well it's good but
it's not really yeah up to the same
standard as the first two were
technically I think it's at the same
standard it's just that the storytelling
isn't quite at the same standard it's a
little
sentimental a little too sentimental
but that's what they wanted to I guess
that's the way they wanted to go with
this I mean it had some [ __ ] epic
scenes some really good
you know my my uh Sonny's one of Sonny's
bastard child children has a son that
kind of appears from nowhere from the
ground up and fights his way to the top
and
falls in love with Michael Corleone's
daughter who their first cousins yeah
and but the [ __ ] still goes down anyway
and um that was kind of the interesting
story kind of an interesting twist it
turned out real bad at the end you know
spoiler alert uh she gets killed
at the very end you know what I mean and
she was like the only good one in the
family really
yeah I mean that was kind of like the
whole
I feel like one of the overarching
themes of the movie was that
um you know he was trying to the whole
reason he got into this whole deal was
to like redeem himself he was trying to
get out of being like a criminal he
wanted to be like a good man he was
trying to like leave all that behind but
you know you couldn't really leave it
behind and it ended up uh having
repercussions for like pretty much the
only innocent member of his family well
he says something that's quite important
in this which is you know is true he
said you know he tried to leave the
criminal life behind and tried to go
straight but the further up he went into
society the more crooked it got
and instead of having honor like
gangsters had they had they were vipers
they had no honor they were just you
know
nasty industrialists basically killing
each other over power it said it got
even worse so there was no way to go
straight
well yeah that's kind of yeah the thing
is that it wasn't a mafia holding him
back I mean he wanted he was like that
yeah but yeah he ended up getting I I
kind of feel like he went in like way
over his head because yeah there's
nothing but gangsters at the top right
and well and that's the thing like he'd
been a gangster before and he made a lot
of money before and he was a big deal
but he got into you know he went into
like a bigger Pond essentially yeah
because you're dealing with like the
[ __ ] this multinational corporation
with like the Catholic church and all
this other stuff involved yeah and
they'll attack you with the helicopters
with machine guns on it you know the
mafia wouldn't come couldn't didn't come
up with [ __ ] like that you know just it
got more and more ruthless as he went to
the top and they were just
different ethnic groups like one of the
dudes he's fighting is a German in
German
okay I just thought he was German and
that was based on that was based on a
real dude some kind of some kind of
Germanic dude and he was [ __ ]
ruthless and they're not gangsters they
didn't come from the street they were
rich people and they were just as worse
or just as bad they just did things a
different way they just had money now
one guy said that Finance is a weapon
you know it's the best gun you could
ever have you know and it was no isn't
that what he said definitely something
like that he goes that Finance is the
real weapon you don't need you know
soldiers and [ __ ] so it's just you know
he couldn't escape that life it got more
convoluted and like I said he and he
eventually got in like way over his head
you know he found out that yeah he was
maybe the boss in that little kind of
thing that they were doing but then he
just went into a whole different Arena
yeah
and then um
yeah he was kind of nostalgic for like
the simpler ways you know it goes back
to [ __ ] Sicily and [ __ ] and uh and
then it turns out that uh [ __ ] half
the Vatican is corrupt as [ __ ]
well and the one guy that was a good guy
that he gave a confession to like that
dude gets poisoned like immediately yeah
by the Archbishop actually poisoned
poisoned him with the tea or whatever I
think yeah
like I said no I there's a kill the pope
somebody says poisoned his ass well see
that's also kind of based on a real
thing too because in 1978
um Pope John Paul the first he wasn't in
there very long and then he died in his
bed right and it's like there's
speculation nobody knows if it's true or
not but there was speculation like some
journalists did speculate that he got
poisoned so they did actually like put
that into the movie so some of the stuff
about that like the Vatican bank and all
that kind of stuff is based on [ __ ] that
really happened and even the guy like
the Swiss dude I think that in the movie
that um that they smother him to make it
look like and then they hang him from
the bridge that really happens to uh to
that guy to that guy's equivalent
um and they're pretty sure that that was
murder yeah the Vatican evidently is one
of the largest uh or uh largest uh
[ __ ] uh real estate holders they own
some [ __ ] super
expensive valuable properties and they
have their own bank
and word has it is that
it's the bank's pretty crooked they'll
help you launder money and stuff or and
CIA evidently might use it for black
budgets and black projects there's no
telling but uh it's bad whatever it is
they're all bad
I think the thing about this well okay
because the first two movies you know
the first movie came out in 1972 right
and then the second one came out in 1974
and Francis Ford Coppola I don't think
he he basically was like well that was
The Godfather story told you know I mean
he didn't really want it to be a Trilogy
necessarily because he thought like that
was the end of the story but I guess
um after a few years uh you know he had
had a couple movies that weren't all
that successful so Paramount came to him
and said hey why don't you do a part
three and he was like okay I guess so
and so he got Mario Puzo you know the
guy that wrote the original novel and
they kind of put together a story and
they started putting together their
story back in 1979
but for whatever reason it just like
never got made and I'm not really sure
they were kicking around like different
ideas I feel like
now the thing about I mean the stuff
about
um you know the Vatican bank and all
that that was like a later that wasn't
in the original script like they are
well the original stuff didn't have
anything to do with the Vatican or
nothing I feel like that was like a
later addition and the thing that was
kind of sad about it too was that you
know Robert Duvall you know who played
Tom Hagen in the other two movies he was
supposed to in the original you know
versions of the script he was supposed
to have like a much bigger role but when
they asked him to be in the movie uh
basically he was mad because they were
paying Al Pacino like four times more
than he was getting paid yeah and he was
just kind of like look if it'd been like
twice as much okay but four times as
much no thank you and he didn't want to
do it so that's why in this version of
the movie they basically just wrote him
out and said oh he died like in between
yeah like his son was in there like he
was going into the into the priesthood
or something like that and they just
like replaced him with a different
character who's played by George
Hamilton right so he was kind of like
the equivalent but he's not the same and
I kind of feel like he's a very tiny
role he didn't say much yeah and I kind
of feel like that's kind of a shame
because I think Robert Duvall was like a
really cool character from the first two
and it would have been cool to like see
a story with him like with a bigger part
in it you know what I mean yeah but I
will say that like I do like the
addition of Andy Garcia I like that
whole thing where he's kind of like he's
uh Sunny's bastard kid right Vincent
yeah yeah and uh so yeah so he shows up
and he basically wants to be a gangster
he's like hey who tell me who to kill
and I'll do it and all this other stuff
well no you know what I mean it's just
he does say something kind of like that
but you know where Michael Corleone is
like Hey we're trying to go legit over
here and then Vincent is all just like
no I want to be a hitman
so there's kind of like and then Connie
like the sister she's kind of like yeah
probably we have some people that need
to get bumped off or whatever but it's
like so there's that whole kind of thing
going on and so um then you have the
whole thing with Vincent I I think the
thing with Vincent and you know uh
hooking up with Mary the daughter played
by Sophia Coppola I think that's kind of
like the strongest thing I the thing
that I mean this is a good movie but I
think it had too much stuff going on
you know what I'm saying yeah well at
the the the characters the enemy
characters were not really driving they
didn't really stick out they were all
kind of generic if you ask me they
didn't it's kind of like they didn't
really have compelling roles either
it was just very much centered around
Michael Corleone I think and
he's in his 50s yeah he's supposed to be
like 59 or 60. yeah but he's supposed to
be like 30 years yeah yeah
but he's pretending to be like in the
60s but he comes off as a dude in his
80s maybe he's almost acting too old
uh yeah I see the way he's walking he's
like uh you know what I mean it's just
not a very compelling character and it
is he's not as interesting as he was
being worried about I guess worrying
about being assassinated yeah he takes
it out of you yeah I suppose but you
know they're just trying to they're just
trying to end the damn story
by uh making this character pay for what
he's done basically he tries to [ __ ]
achieve salvation and it is denied you
know he didn't he didn't get he didn't
get uh
without salvation what's the word I'm
looking for Redemption Redemption yeah
he tries to get Redemption it doesn't
really happen per se he has to suffer a
lot
and uh yeah he lives until he's old but
he has to live with the knowledge that
like his
actions uh led to certain outcomes yes
consequences which kind of reminds me of
uh that it may be related to
um
to uh milius's first Conan the Barbarian
because that was going to be a Trilogy
too
and it was going to be
uh
it was gonna have kind of Nichi and
philosophies about how to rise up out of
nothing and turn yourself into something
and then you know this would be your
youth middle age and then old age
and the the third it didn't go that way
uh [ __ ] Dino DiLaurentis Studios
didn't want to hire Milius he was too
much too much money and they wanted to
they wanted a basically a PG movie and
it didn't work out but
the third one was supposed to be
consequences for what for this [ __ ]
rise
in yourself you know what I mean
consequences and how to stay relevant in
old age
and uh I think it was going to be called
King Conan I think again
but um that's kind of what this movie is
consequences for all the other [ __ ] that
you for the [ __ ] that you did during
your during your rise
because I kind of feel like at this
stage in his life you know like I said
he's it's very important to him that
he'd go legit he's been like trying to
just
like I said just redeem himself by
giving all this money to Charities and
like trying to get in on this like
Vatican deal and all this other kind of
stuff to make himself look like squeaky
clean like that's gonna erase
I think in particular it's not even so
much the stuff they did I kind of feel
like in particular what haunts him is
that he had Fredo killed yeah I think
that's what bothers him more than
anything because that's kind of the
thing that
that he brings up yeah that he brings up
all the time like during the confession
and like he starts crying and stuff like
that so I don't think he's all that
bothered about the other bad [ __ ] he did
yeah but I think that is really like
haunting him that he actually went there
and did that I don't know if Coppola and
Milius knew each other maybe just that
three that trilogy three-story Arc is
common yeah it is probably what it is I
don't know if if Copeland was inspired
by what Milius was talking about what he
was going to do with Conan but it's that
same basic story arc that Milius had
envisioned for Conan that I would have
loved to have seen millions of Conan
[ __ ] two and three been [ __ ] great
but that's the thing I kind of feel like
you know particularly screenplays where
you get three act structure and it's
like three stages of life you know youth
middle age and yeah yeah and being old
it's just very common so it is like a
very common common classic [ __ ] story
right right and I feel like that's kind
of what this movie I feel like this was
the most operatic of all of them and not
just because yeah there's an opera at
the end of it I just feel like the tone
of it and I think that was another thing
that kind of threw me off a little
because I kind of feel like the first
two and I know that there was like a
long period of time in between you know
the first two and this one but I kind of
feel like the first two were kind of I
don't know if I'd call them low-key but
it's not as this one seemed some of the
characters and stuff like that or some
of the acting seemed a little
overwrought well the first two were
grounded in reality right this one's
kind of reaching there man come on
he's getting awards from the pope he
knows the pope [ __ ] you know I mean
it's it's almost like fantasy
there's some great scenes in it but some
of it kinda
you gotta suspend your disbelief yeah I
mean it's just that doesn't I don't know
that was just I mean like I said it gets
very grandiose it gets real yeah that's
a good word that's a good word like I
said it just seems like and I kind of
feel like too because they set Michael
Corleone up in the first two movies and
yes it's the same actor but they set him
up in the first two movies as being
not
not cold or sociopathic or anything like
that he's just very pragmatic and he
doesn't I mean yeah he's probably like
upset that he has to do certain things
but he keeps everything like very close
to his vest he keeps everything like
just he doesn't have these big outbursts
of emotion or anything like that like
yeah he might be feeling all that stuff
deep down but he doesn't let that show
whereas I kind of feel like in this one
and maybe that was you know
um just kind of like where he was at in
his life because it's been like so many
years but he did seem like real
over this or like more over raw in this
one yeah and maybe that's like I said I
get what they were going for because
it's like now he's you know approaching
old age like he's 60 or whatever however
old he's supposed to be I think he's
supposed to be about 60. and because he
says it's like 30 years later and he's
realizing like he's having like a lot of
regrets about like [ __ ] that he did in
his life and it's like how he [ __ ]
over K and like you know how he's trying
to like control his son and make him go
back to law school even though his son
doesn't want to do that like he wants to
be an opera singer and he's trying to be
kind of be in a butthole about that but
then like he lets him go and like all
this other stuff and then he's trying to
like protect Mary his daughter and then
like Vincent comes in like trying to get
involved with that and so he's afraid
that he's that Vincent's gonna put her
in danger and so he's trying to you know
at the end of his life I guess he wants
to make like the kind of money that will
keep his family like going forever like
he wants to be one of the most powerful
families in the world so to make sure
that they're taken care of but his past
just keeps catching up with him and
maybe that's and he just can't like hold
it in anymore maybe but I do kind of
feel like I don't know I feel like there
was like a little bit of a too much of a
tonal shift between the character he was
playing in the earlier films and the
character that he plays in this one well
a lot of time is supposed to pass like
that's what yeah that's what I'm saying
so I get that and the thing too is that
when this movie came out in 1990 you
know this was
I I was watching like another uh review
of this and they said like a really
insightful thing they said at the time
that this movie came out Al Pacino was
bigger than Michael Corleone he was much
bigger than the character yeah and I
kind of feel like that because he was
young like in the first one so he wasn't
I mean he was well known but he wasn't
as well known as he was in 1990. yeah a
lot of the original cast came back
they had uh who's who's the actress that
played uh Connie
um Talia Shire Talia shires who is
Francis Ford Coppola's sister yeah
it was wow on me man every time she
showed up she was in these fantastic
outfits kind of this [ __ ] yeah she has
some great outfits she's very thin and
her hair is done right and she's these
black outfits with gold accents and
stuff and she just she just held
together she's got to be in her maybe
mid 50s in it and she's just still
gorgeous woman you know what I mean very
elegant looking
um and she did a great job
a great job yeah I liked her I liked her
a lot in this because yeah because she
was kind of the one yeah it almost
seemed and maybe I'm just reading too
much into it but it almost kind of
seemed like she was seeing how Michael
was like maybe getting away from the
whole crime because it seemed like her
and Vincent were kind of like yeah why
don't you go like like yeah she was
vibing with Vincent she's like yeah we
need to go kill that dude like without
she was becoming Consulting yeah she was
becoming kind of the substitute
Godfather right on underground she was
handling gangster [ __ ] right and you see
he's going down the same way his dad
went when he was getting old and
sentimental and he was getting weak yeah
and people were starting to gun and gun
for him so she needed she knew that she
needed gangsters to watch out for him he
was getting too sentimental he was
slipping remember just like they killed
what's his dad was dead and it was veto
right Vito yeah Vito was getting
sentimental he just wanted to go out and
play in the garden with his kids and die
of a heart attack yeah you know I mean
he did but that was discovered yeah
the Heavenly way that was the best way
against her dad playing with his
grandchildren but um
that was kind of the uh that was kind of
the the mode Michael was in he was kind
of he wanted to retire and in the end he
did
um make uh Sonny's son a Corleone change
his last name and basically made him
Godfather yeah that was a really cool
scene yeah and the damn throne and
they're coming and they're kissing this
ring and calling him Don Corleone and
she hadn't [ __ ] you know Don Michael
Corleone and [ __ ] and so he inherited
the gangster throne
he's like I want to run my Straight
businesses you know which I thought that
was a great scene
you know yeah he gets he gets the uh he
becomes is shrined yeah with the
gangster [ __ ]
uh regalia not really it wasn't physical
regalia just a spiritually he becomes a
Godfather yeah I thought that was really
cool although we were speculating and
maybe again we were reading too much
into this because I was reading like
through the plot synopsis and everything
I don't think anybody else really
mentioned this but I was wondering
because you know how I'm just assuming
that most people that are here have like
seen this already so they know like what
we're talking about
but you know how Vincent he kind of went
undercover like he was kind of like a
mole like trying to figure out because
obviously like people were trying to pop
like Michael accordingly they left it on
and see well yeah well see Vincent so he
goes in to find out what the [ __ ]
going on and who it was that ordered the
hit
and all this other stuff so he's
pretending that he turned on Michael
Corley it may have been a double agent
but we're but I'm sitting there thinking
well wait it's like did he really is he
really loyal to Michael Corleone or is
he playing both sides I couldn't really
make sure you never really knew and they
didn't really tell you like I'm assuming
now but I have a feeling that he
betrayed
uh uh Michael Corleone
but I also don't think he realized that
his cousin was going to get shot that
was just well yeah I don't think he
didn't want her to get shot
he had to pay for the Betrayal I think
he betrayed him I think that's what they
see that's what I thought that that's
kind of what they were getting at but
maybe like I said maybe I was reading
too much into it because like then he
was leaving it open
and just waiting for where the chips
were going to fall and then he would
ride either way either way that's kind
of what I was thinking that he was more
like opportunist look but maybe I was
like more of a gangster wait yeah maybe
I was like reading too much into it but
I'm because we're watching it and then
like the last scene like you know on the
at the opera house like on the steps
where Mary gets killed and then you know
obviously
Vincent's all upset about that
but I was sitting there going well was
he playing both sides I think he was but
look you gotta understand there's a lot
of Italian history involved in this this
is the same way Octavian came to power
to become Augustus yeah all right
somebody killed Julius Caesar who was
his adopted father
although he was probably behind it
Octavian and then afterwards he was able
to rise up and and seek revenge on
anybody who killed his father and
[ __ ] he could divide fairies from
[ __ ] fairy boats and warships you're
either with me or you're against me and
he became the emperor the first emperor
of Rome
so
uh Victor could have done the same thing
after all that [ __ ] went down he's now
Justified to seek revenge okay for what
happened to Mary and how Michael was
destroyed did Michael actually die he
was shot too wasn't he he was shot but
he wasn't he's like he wasn't hurt bad
but he was out of the game well yeah
because they showed him later like as an
old man yeah yeah so he's out he died at
the end he was like an old man so you
know he uh Victor now had justification
to just run amok
right and solidify his command and
become basically basically Mafia emperor
of his little fiefdom of his family so
that's probably what he did which was
that was he done it on the name of
[ __ ] avenging
the best girl they had in the family
morally she was the best girl uh she
would didn't do anything wrong she was
an innocent and it crushed [ __ ]
Michael who was there
prior Godfather who had the biggest
status he'd even been blessed by the
pope and gotten those Awards and [ __ ] so
he's Justified to do anything in the
gangster world after that
and if you didn't join up with him
you're an enemy so you could die that
kind of deal
so he'd have been a great political
position
inside that organization and then I was
thinking well was that Vincent's plan
from the beginning probably not well
because the thing about it is you have
to think that he just showed up at that
party yeah at the beginning and he what
you could tell he wasn't really invited
remember in the second movie Michael was
doing that he just he didn't know who
had betrayed him so what he'd do is he
just put pressure on everybody and ask
questions on everybody pretend it's like
he already knew for sounding like yeah
this [ __ ]
so he's playing it by ear it's just that
you had they had a good what was called
command presence which is kind of like
stage presence he didn't let his didn't
drop his guard let anybody knew that he
didn't know he he said no I know who did
it you know yeah he would tell each of
them that he thought the other
[ __ ] yeah yeah he's getting to
throw in all these crosses until
somebody slipped up and he goes oh
that's him right there yeah so that's
what he was doing he didn't know who was
going to win
and like yeah so he was actually playing
both sides because he was inside
Michael's organization because that was
his you know Uncle essentially right
yeah Mike but then he went undercover
with Alta Bello and all those Michael
got killed he'd take credit with the
Enemy organization that did it and he'd
get promoted by them if Michael didn't
get killed he'd [ __ ] yeah
the other way that's what he's doing
yeah that's kind of what I was thinking
yeah and maybe he was I don't know if he
was planning that exact thing from the
beginning but I think he was planning on
getting in there somehow because like I
said he showed up at that big party at
the beginning and nobody was like and if
they killed Michael and he'd take credit
with the Enemy organization get promoted
later on he'd avenge him
just because just because he was in on
it or pretended to be in on it he still
would have Avenged his death later on
when it was operated you know what I
mean okay you killed my you killed my
father type of deal you know but you
killed my uncle yeah you know my
godfather so you know I'm gonna kill you
now and I'm gonna take your [ __ ] so I
can have my [ __ ] and your [ __ ] because
Vincent was really into like hey let's
take revenge on that [ __ ] yeah
he was that type of dude because it
didn't happen by my hand you just
imagined it happened by my hand I betray
you you know that says what they did
Charlie crosses and double crosses
that's well yeah that's kind of what I
would say that's why I think like in the
in this movie I think Vincent is a way
more interesting character than Michael
is yeah even though Michael is the main
character and that's kind of who the
movie is about thematically but I think
Vincent is the most interesting
character yeah I wish there would have
been more Vincent in it
yeah it needed more and uh what was your
name uh Amy no what was it Mary Mary I
mean yeah Mary I thought Mary was
interesting that was Coppola's daughter
yeah
they wanted to get Winona Ryder to play
that Winona Ryder was original well
actually Julia Roberts was the first
choice Winona would have been better
better than Julia Roberts but I think
Winona would have been kind of generic
some people said that this girl couldn't
Act
yeah this was like her and she didn't
really want to do it because it's kind
of like I thought she could I thought
she did a great job and I thought she
looked right Winona kind of had she
doesn't look that Italian if you ask me
Winona doesn't even though she was only
playing a half Italian birth uh girl she
looks a little too innocent a little too
generic looking
this girl looked Italian she had the
well she is
she's pretty uh but not in a Hollywood
pretty just pretty uh look like a girl
you'd actually know from an Italian
family and I like that now that I
thought that worked yeah
you know you do you don't want
you don't want [ __ ] um Michael
Corleone's daughter to look like a
supermodel it's it suspends this you
know what I mean that would be dumb it'd
be dumb you want her to look like a good
looking
real Italian chick you know that's what
it looked that's what she looked like so
I thought that was great
yeah it just it seemed like that was the
main when this movie came out it seemed
like that was the main criticism yeah
um that they thought that she was like a
shitty actress I even thought I think
she even got nominated for a couple like
uh golden raspberry Awards and stuff
like that it's ridiculous
no and well the thing about it is that
like I said I don't think she really
wanted me and this is just like the
actors that they had to be in it because
like I said we're not a writer was
supposed to be in it and then like she
got sick or something like that and she
couldn't do it and so Francis Ford
Coppola was like hey it's who his
daughter like hey you want to be in it
she's like not really which is like they
put her in there anyway I was like but I
mean Sophia Copeland she got the last
laugh because she went on to become like
a really good director like in her own
right so you know didn't she do Lost in
Translation and what else am I thinking
that she did didn't she do The Virgin
Suicides that was the movie too there's
nothing wrong with her acting in here I
thought it was good acting she's a
believable character now I will say that
I will say that Roger Ebert went to bat
for her like a lot of a lot of people
were kind of like oh she's not that good
but he he liked that pretty much the
same thing you said it's like he liked
how natural she was like a real person
like she didn't come across like an
actress or anything like when she was
kind of more seemed like a real genuine
yeah like she had like a real Italian
chick you know then you ran running into
him all the time up in Boston you know
what I mean like a real Italian-American
type girl that's the way they looked and
that's kind of the way they were you
know so I thought she I thought she was
perfect for the role
Winona there's star power there Instant
Star Power I mean it would have worked I
think it worked but she'd have been out
of what other ones she'd been better
Julia Roberts but no I can't yeah I
can't really see Julia Roberts in that
role no I thought Miss Coppola worked
man yeah yeah I thought she was good you
know [ __ ] I no if you'd have told me
that yeah she's not an actress I would
have disbelieved you because
look like an address to me yeah I
believed that character I believed in a
character I liked her character
remember she's sitting there making eyes
that are uh what's his name uh uh Victor
and I'm going she's way into that dude
benefit yeah so you know I'm seeing it
you know so yeah she's acting yeah yeah
because you believed that she was like
yeah that she wanted to jump on that D
yeah it was she did but she did jump on
there or at least in the story you know
yeah we don't know if she jumped on that
day in real life probably not
Straw Dogs 78 said Vincent Corleone ear
biter cousin poker Godfather
well the cousin the cousin thing
that's some old school [ __ ] there you
know what I mean that was going on in
Europe
even in Germany you know what I mean
back in the 30s a lot of people
preferred to marry first cousins did you
know a lot of people don't know that you
know mustache man of the German of the
the Germans of the BET cross his first
like big relationship was girl named
galey gaily Hitler
I think her last name was Hitler I think
it was pretty much Kelly and she killed
herself over him because he had
fooled around on her or something and it
was like in style back then for a woman
to attempt suicide over a man to like
prove her love there's a whole German
cultural thing back in the 20s and the
30s about that
they were into cousins and
um suicide attempts she shot herself in
the stomach I think with a 25. God damn
why did you do that she thought she'd
survive it
I think even if you did you probably
wish you were done she didn't survive
she she lived she layered for a few days
and then died but she tried to
give me that [ __ ] Jesus Christ
well the funny thing about it being
worth it evidently that [ __ ] was
popular with women uh during his rise
before he actually became Chancellor and
everything evidently he was popular
women liked him and um
even when he was in control you know I
mean he didn't want anybody to know that
he had a girlfriend or married to Ava
because that would have affected
negatively affected his popularity with
the German Deutsche folk with the the
German women because he was a sex symbol
he said what brought him to power was
German female voters they liked that guy
which he thought he was sexy that's
crazy things change
well yeah I guess so yeah uh Sebastian
says is the Blu-ray theatrical and
director's cut editions it sounds very
good we have um Louie sent us the like
the box set the trilogy and it has a
bonus disc yeah it has the first one the
second one it doesn't have the
theatrical cut of the third one it has
The Godfather Coda the death of Michael
Corleone which is basically like a
slightly recut uh version of the
restored original what they were right
what they wanted like and that came out
in 2020 and then there's like a bonus
disc which has like all the extra stuff
on it which we haven't watched yet
actually isn't there one more disc in
there there's one more disc in there
it's got a bunch of bonus stuff on no I
said there I thought there was another
disc aside from there's four dish total
oh okay yeah so it's like so there's
another three movies so there's so the
theatrical cut of part three is actually
not in the set because like I said the
one that came in on 2020 that was
recapped by Francis Ford Coppola I heard
it's not that different you know what I
mean like I think in the theatrical cut
you know at the very end like when they
show Michael and he's old and he's
sitting in the garden I think they
actually show him like slumping over and
dying in the garden just got it
basically like his dad did kinda but you
know not not as happy in ending but in
this version they don't actually show
him like slumping over and dying they
just kind of show him like oh he's gonna
die or something like that like they
don't really go that far and I think
like the opening scene is different and
some of the other scenes are shuffled
around but I heard it wasn't all that
different from the theatrical cut but
what was what is funny we're talking
about the cousin thing
uh is that
it is mentioned that they're first
cousins but only once and never in a
negative way
so that must have been kind of a retro
Italian thing they didn't think you see
it was an issue they thought it was a
security risk for him to be with a woman
that was so closely related
because they would Target or try to kill
her to get at him so that that's yeah so
I'm thinking that it was it wasn't so
much that they were cousins it was
that she was a high value Target right
is what it was they wanted him to be
with a woman who wasn't as high value to
the family
yeah because I mean that was the
Godfather's daughter and like obviously
should I make a nice juicy Target you
could kill them both and especially when
Vincent was out there like doing revenge
and like killing people and stuff so
yeah because uh Michael told him says
they don't if they can't come after you
they come after the people you care
about right Jesus that's my daughter
yeah so that's why like you told him
yeah you need to like knock that [ __ ]
off so I don't know old school Italian
um Traditions uh it's probably like Old
Germany old old-fashioned Germany where
the cousins they didn't care
yeah
Tom Sykes says cannolis are lethal as
[ __ ] in this film that's what I was
thinking too she took a little nibble of
it though Connie just she didn't get
enough maybe yeah she probably just
she's like well let's see maybe all the
poison is in the cream part in the
middle so I'm just gonna like take a
little nibble on this part look I'm
totally eating it or maybe she didn't
maybe she just like pretended to eat it
like stuck it under her tongue or
something like that and that poison I
don't know what kind of poison it was
but it took a while to kill that dude
like it took almost the whole Opera
like what and I don't know how many of
them he ate Samantha B saying she was
terrible I don't know who she's talking
about must be talking about probably
Sophia Coppola yeah she wasn't terrible
strong 78 said I liked uh I liked Sophia
Coppola I think part of the problem in
the first cut was her dubbing I think
the ADR was awful in that cut maybe
that's what it was okay because I'm not
sure if that's been fixed like in this
version I don't know because yeah I
didn't notice anything I haven't seen
the theatrical version yeah I didn't
notice any dubbing and this one just
seemed like a normal voice yeah maybe
that's what I wanted
hahaha
um Ben says Austrian painter was banging
one of his nieces
was it
yikes that's kind of that's [ __ ] up
uh but yeah uh Ben said everyone made
out that Godfather 3 was biographical
for the copolas or something I mean
I don't know what I was thinking though
like in the in the scene where
where Mary gets shot at the end and then
like Al Pacino is just losing his
[ __ ] mind over it and then I'm
sitting there going that must have been
really weird I don't know maybe it's not
but it must have been really weird for
Francis Ford Coppola to like shoot a
scene where his daughter is like getting
killed and that's because like you know
like because that's like the daughter in
a movie No and then she's like Dad and
then she like like flops over that's not
weird it's all make believe to them I
know but it's like I don't know if that
was really your kid I would think that
that would upset you a little bit I
don't think so maybe nah I mean it would
make money it would probably think oh
that old Italian dude putting his
daughter in the sex scenes all the time
yeah just with his nude well yeah see
but that's really weird though I always
thought you care though I always thought
that was really weird of course that's
weird that he would put because I was
like why do you keep putting your
daughters yeah in your movies and it's
like oh let's have her get horribly
raped in this one several times he's
Italian and then he did that one um
we're doing it for the art I guess yeah
and then he did that one what was the
one where she was um anorexic or bulimic
or whatever and there was that weird
scene of her like taping down her boobs
yeah [ __ ] man what movie was that I
don't know I can't remember it was the
one where it's I just watched it like
the other day yeah that's what Richard
Brown said Terry Orchard does it all the
time that's what I thought but see I
always think it's weird every time I see
one of Dario's movies with Asia in it
and she gets like brutalized I'm just
kind of like Jesus Christ what is that
set like it must be really awkward I
can't imagine like my dad's not a movie
director obviously but I can't imagine
being in a movie shot by my dad where I
had to like do that it would just be so
so strange yeah maybe it's not like the
worst ones Klaus kids key though because
he was doing [ __ ] like that for [ __ ]
real with his daughters well yeah that's
true at least one of them but it's like
a nasty [ __ ] he's [ __ ] crazy crazy
but see as far as I know Dario Argento
didn't do anything it's like a lot of
people think it's weird just because but
I mean you know Asia is like pretty I
mean obviously she's a grown person
[ __ ] Dario gender was just trying to
make us make his daughter famous and
trying to make money like it worked I
guess
so uh let's go ahead and shut this down
I'll get us something to eat all right
so we got I think it was Tom Sykes sent
me a message earlier and or put a
message on one of the videos earlier and
gave us a recommendation for The
Haunting show tomorrow which was
Nightmare in the Attic
from season seven so unless somebody has
a better idea that's we have season
seven right yeah yeah okay
so that's the one we'll do because I
think we've covered most of the first
four seasons so yeah he said season
seven episode nine all right so that's
the one that's the one we'll probably do
uh tomorrow and then I think on Tuesday
because what happened in the patreon
poll for the movies Godfather 3 tied
with Todd Browning's freaks
so maybe we'll do freaks on Tuesday
because I've been wanting to I've been
wanting to like re-watch that for a long
time so we'll do some more 30s movies
and stuff like that so uh so yeah so uh
come back tomorrow at 6 00 PM Eastern
Standard Time for haunting Mondays we'll
be talking about nightmare in the attic
and thanks everybody for dropping by
have a good rest of your weekend and
evening and we'll see you again tomorrow
good night